passez par vaccination digital pour moi
c'est tout à fait normal puis on a des
équipes qui sont en train de regarder ça
j'ai demandé à ce qu'on peut savoir qui
serait nous continuité logique de ce
qu'il ya dans le carnet santé et c'est
qui qui passe par par la ram qu est tout
à fait normal un passeport vaccinale est
ce que laisse le prolongement d'un
carnet santé à quoi servirait-il
favorisera-t-il un déconfinement on a
pensé poser la question sur les enjeux
éthiques a doctor verdi travées du quai
professeur de bioéthique au département
de médecine sociale et préventive de
l'école de santé publique à l'université
de montréal je me suis entretenu avec
elle
en fin d'après midi bonsoir madame ravi
disque et bienvenue à 24,60 bonsoir le
gouvernement à bord de la question nos
passeports vaccinale aujourd'hui est-ce
que selon vous ça favoriserait un retour
à la vie normale d'un déconfinement à je
suis très contre cette idée à écouter la
pandémie a déjà tellement exacerbées les
inéquités dans notre société
l'impact sur la population a marginalisé
a été beaucoup plus grave pour moi c'est
encore un moyen d' exacerber ces
inéquité oui ça va donner que ça va
bénéficier quelques personnes mais il
faut considérer que ça va aussi craint
des barrières d'accès pour d'autres
personnes
c'est pas tout le monde qui va avoir le
même accès aux vaccins
les personnes qui habitent en région par
exemple peuvent ne pas avoir le même
accès elle sait pas tout le monde qui
est un téléphone intelligent pour
télécharger cette application
surtout les populations plus âgées
souvent non pacsés intéressante donc
toutes ces propositions pour moi ça va
créer des discriminations non justifiées
et exacerber davantage le problème que
la pandémie a déjà créé parce qu'il
n'est pas d'obligation d'être vacciné il
ya des personnes qui pour des raisons
médicales ne peuvent pas le recevoir en
même temps on semble comprendre que on
veut favoriser la relance économique
donc on veut donner l'accès au
restaurant au jim en vue
donner de l'oxygène à la population
enfin celle approche que le gouvernement
semble avoir en disant c'est peut-être
la continuité du passeport santé ou du
carnet de santé est seulement la
continuité du carnet de santé
écoutez hélios ici un autre angle à
considérer on sait bien que le vaccin
est très efficace pour garantir qu'on va
pas tomber gravement malade mais on ne
sait pas encore si les personnes
vaccinées ne peuvent pas transmettre le
virus aux autres à quel est le sens de
donner accès aux personnes vaccinées aux
événements concerts musées cinémas reste
aux centres commerciaux
si ces personnes ne peuvent toujours
propager le virus de le transmettre aux
autres ça diminue beaucoup la
justification de ce type de
discrimination
au delà de ce problème qui est peut-être
un problème scientifique
il y a le problème de ceux qui ces
personnes non vaccinées
c'est pas tout le monde ainsi vaccin
théories de conspiration il y a les
personnes avec des conditions médicales
préalable comme vous venez de dire
qu'ils ne peuvent pas se faire vacciner
il y a les populations moins étudiaient
les femmes enceintes les femmes qui
allaitent
hélas elles ont raison toujours de près
et enzo poupaud peut-être des
préoccupations par rapport au vaccin qui
peuvent être justifiées elles veulent
peut-être attendre encore un petit peu
pour voir si on apprend plus sur
l'impact
il ya des personnes qui hésitent
peut-être c'est pas l'idéal d'hésiter
mais il ya des gens qui ont des raisons
c'est pas tout le monde je vais jamais
me faire vacciner peu importe le bien
commun donc il approche plus nuancée il
y aura on aura besoin de plusieurs
d'exception si on utilise c'était
applications ce certificat de vaccins et
si on a plusieurs d'exception c'est
moins efficace donc pourquoi le faire
dans les mêmes temps quand monsieur dubé
d'ixelles a continué la continuité du
carnet de santé
c'est pas est-ce qu'on peut comparer le
carnet de santé que chacun a avec
certificat de vaccination comme celui là
absolument non est-ce que jamais vous on
vous a demandé de voir votre carnet de
santé pour entrer
dans un centre commercial est ce que le
contenu de votre carnet de santé agents
mais crée des barrières d'accès pour
vouziers pour aller au supermarché
dans le passé on a utilisé des vaccins
des exigences de vaccins pour des
voyages à l'étranger pour quelques pays
là je veux comprendre si on part à
l'étranger
il faut un visa et sans accent s'il ya
des précédents mais limitations sur le
mouvement sur l'accès au magasin aux
événements des barrières pour la vie
sociale sur la base d'un carnet de santé
c'est sans précédent et c'est pas justin
mais aussi on a fait des entrevues avec
un directeur de l'iata ya quelques jours
sur le projet pilote que l'iata donc
l'organisation civile qui veut tester la
possibilité d'exiger de certains
passagers sur certaines lignes aériennes
d'avoir ce passeport vaccinale mais rien
ne paraissait très simple cela dit
parler doute l'exemple d'israël
je crois vous connaissez bien parce que
c'est une population très vacciner on
introduit des badges de couleurs une
dose de doses enfin pour justement
réguler les déplacements des personnes
que pensez-vous de l'exemple d'israël à
cet égard et je pense que c'est
prématuré pas justifiée je trouve qu'il
faut une approche nuancée par rapport à
quelle limite ça va créer 6 est utilisé
pour les personnes qui travaillent dans
les hôpitaux up en personne avec des
patients les personnes qui travaillent
dans des établissements de longue durée
y ait un risque très élevé là peut être
un peu justifiée mais à grande échelle
pour limiter toutes les activités
quotidiennes
je sais que c'est proposer utilisé en
israël je trouve pas que ce soit
justifié
non ça semble assez étrange au sud pour
le temps et bruges d'adopter des badges
de couleur si vous me permettez là le
lien ou écoutez moi même je suis
raelienne et j'ai donné pas mal d'entre
eux vu dans les médias maliens parce que
je trouve que le gouvernement n'a pas
vraiment réfléchi sur les enjeux
éthiques s'était présenté comme si c'est
évident en clair un peu comme ça a été
présenté aujourd'hui en québec
comme s'il y a aucun souci aucune
préoccupation éthique aucun impact
discriminatoire au niveau de la société
c'est jeudi il faut une approche nuancée
ça peut peut-être être je suis fier à
courtin dans certains contextes mais pas
adopté comme si c'est banal trivial
aucune réflexion
en même temps ils répandent des recours
légaux sur la base du respect de la
charte des droits et libertés en vertu
de la charte des gens pourraient
évidemment j'imagine contestées il y
avait déjà un avis publié de la part
d'un certain groupe qui a réclamé que
c'est contre la constitution que ses
indics constitutionnel de de mettre en
oeuvre ce type de certificats dans la
vraie vie merci de nous avoir parlé ce
soir
merci beaucoup